I Know Who I am we have finished with  you you'll no longer with yourself I  remember I remember everything  remembering everything doesn't mean you  know everything tell me we've just been  hacked could be worse than Snowden  facial recognition got it hit Jesus  Christ that's Jason Bourne  why would he come back now  there's a demonstration in front of the  Greek parliament building I think she'll  use it as cover  they tracked you we got to move  he's same things he knows things what if  he's not coming for us  what if it's something else I  volunteered because of a lie this is  Jason Bourne I need to talk  32 kills people are safer because of  what you did  you never gonna find any peace not till  you admit to yourself who you really are  this is dia this is Jay